in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Dustin
and Sara are with us welcome guys how
are you hi Dave we're great doing a
great Dave thanks welcome where are you
guys from San Francisco Wow all the way
on the other side of the United States
to Nashville to do a debt free scream
yeah Wow how much have you paid off
$50,000 very good and how long did that
take about twenty two months good for
you and your range of income during that
time yeah we started off making 95
combined and now we're at 150 Wow in two
years yeah what happened to your income
well you said increase your income so we
did just like that yeah that was easy no
we uh we were blessed we both got two
different promotions within the same
companies and you know our journey
started before San Francisco really what
led us to do this was we moved there and
we saw all the prices for rents and
everything else and that was that was
the motivation yeah to say hey you know
if we're gonna take this opportunity for
careers we got to get serious about this
what kind of debt was the 50,000 so we
had about 30,000 in student loan 15,000
in a car and five and credit cards okay
a little bit everything cool so 22
months ago was the San Francisco move
yes and that was the catalyst to cause
you to start this so you said okay we
gotta attack this then what you do yeah
so you know we're probably
first-generation I guess of every dollar
that was a huge thing for us but it was
really you know when we saw the rents
and you know just we from Florida know
income state tax and get to California
we're like holy smokes attacked you own
everything Yeah right taxi to breathe it
was definitely doing the written budget
and kind of planning what we have to cut
and we used to think we had a disposable
income with debt and that's not the case
and we kind of had to come to that
realization mmm okay all right so you
sit down and do a budget you get on
every dollar right and you get an attack
mode
so what was the hardest part of the last
22 months I think not eating out not
experiencing San Francisco I work in the
hospitality industry so a lot of us will
go to new restaurants or bars and you
know experience and we couldn't we had
to stay back or you know we did things
on a lighter scale and that was a
sacrifice that we made and we can made
it too so yeah you know I would say
throughout this whole journey Dave are
our roles kind of flopped in the
beginning I was the much stronger one
and really saying no no to everything
and then as I saw the light you know at
the end of the tunnel it kind of flopped
where hey maybe we can kind of do this
and now and my advice for everybody else
is you know this isn't a 50-50 thing
this is a hundred percent 100 percent
everybody because when the other person
needs help you've got to step in and
fill in the gaps then okay so you were
you're letting your foot off the gas no
Sara so Matt you know I can see the
finish line No
yeah good I love it very fun good for
you guys so really what you're saying is
is the budget and working together where
you're two big things that cost you to
break through yeah and we you know just
towards the end really envisioning I
think towards the last few months Dave
we were throwing something like $2,800 a
month just to get this stuff out of the
way like that money is gonna be ours
soon know how does it feel now you don't
have any payments feel rich yeah it's
like a huge weight off your shoulders we
did their first monthly budget and then
we had all this money left over and of
course that's going to our emergency
fund in our savings but it's like wow
you know this is something that we can
use to finish and complete some of our
future goals and travel and do the
things that we really want to do and
we're passionate about so got your life
back yeah yeah how long have you guys
been married December 1st is four years
all right very cool so two years in the
mess and two years out of the manor
actually we met here in Nashville
Tennessee Wow okay cool
well it's good to have you guys thanks
for coming in I'm proud of you very
proud of you and got you got to feel
good about yourself she'd done a great
hear you very well done so uh Chris
Hogan's new book number one bestseller
retire inspired is the next chapter to
continue to build wealth and give
outrageously and so we're gonna help you
by giving you a copy of that son by Hill
yeah I say thank you for coming all the
way to Nashville to do your debt-free
screen very fun alright it's Dustin and
Sarah San Francisco $50,000 paid off in
22 months making 95 to 150 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream okay three
where to go you guys way to go man
that's awesomeness right there very very
well done hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show